this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by pdsdet
Stanley Kubrick is considered one of the
greatest filmmakers of all time of his
13 movies a few are considered Classics
but in 1968 Kubrick released 2001 A
Space Odyssey and this is more than a
classic it's a masterpiece and widely
regarded as one of the best science
fiction films of all time and probably
the most influential this collaboration
with science fiction author Arthur C
Clarke tells the story of an alien
intelligence that visited Earth in the
distant past and left behind artifacts
in the solar system the movie features
groundbreaking special effects which
still hold up today in fact the effects
looked so good that the movie gave the
American government an idea billions of
tax dollars were invested in the space
program but the Soviets were still years
ahead of the United States NASA
desperately needed to get to the moon
before Russia but they knew it was
impossible so they turned to one of the
world's best filmmakers for help because
when it came to the Moon if they
couldn't make it they fake it
thank you
I mean what's the worst that can happen
[Music]
I told you to stop messing with that
thing it's full of many demons oh come
on how bad could it be
don't do it
hey look I don't have time to babysit
you right now I sent you an important
parcel yeah I didn't get any
yeah see
[Music]
I guess it's this
inside the vanilla envelope is an
important document I need you to sign
did you see vanilla envelope will you
hurry up Gertie is freezing a hot boss
out here hang on baby daddy's on the
phone yeah I know I know
uh this is a purchase agreement for a
dog sled team yeah
with a custom built heated seat and a
camel sized sidecar oh yeah
and it's gotta be heated so my water
don't freeze yeah I'm not sure how this
involves me well look at the last
I'm listed on this document yep
as a co-signer yep and when Gertie and I
went next year's I did a ride oh we'll
thank you in a victory speech yeah I
don't think Johnny Hancock
I know baby give Daddy to deal with the
human yeah I'm not signing this
open your house Collections and if you
just give it a raise then this wouldn't
be an issue but no Mr big shot says he
can't because he's such a cheapskate I
can hear you
why don't you just call PDS debt oh
yep PDS debt rolls all your payments
into one low zero percent interest
monthly payment everyone with over ten
thousand dollars or more in debt
qualifies and there's no minimum credit
score required bad and Fair Credit is
accepted you can save thousands in
interest and fees and pay off your debt
in a fraction of the time
PDS debt is offering a free debt savings
analysis to our qualified viewers just
for completing a 30 second online
assessment click the link in the
description or go to pdsdeath.com files
that's
pdsdebt.com files yes and then I can get
the dog select team well you can but I
don't know if that's a sound financial
decision
[Music]
you know this isn't healthy right I know
oh look I gotta go uh but straight that
document well yeah it's got my real name
on it really
your real name
[Music]
from the moment that Neil Armstrong and
Buzz Aldrin set foot on the moon on July
20th 1969 rumors were circulating that
the whole thing was faked that's because
it was fake yeah I know you believe that
I believe it because it's true well
we're gonna explore the theory but
they're not a theory the moon landing
was fake yeah but can you be quiet for
one minute while I set this up please
fine fine go ahead shut up your theory
thank you
it was fake
science journalist Richard C Hoagland
wrote in his 2007 book dark mission that
he saw NASA press officers helping
distribute Flyers to the Press saying
the landing was faked even though the
astronauts brought back hundreds of moon
rocks and took thousands of photographs
of the Moon some people simply didn't
believe it considering the technology of
the time going to the moon and back
sounded like science fiction at one
point almost 30 percent of the American
public believe the moon landings had
been faked and this started to show up
in pop culture in the 1971 movie
diamonds are forever there's a sequence
where Sean Connery as James Bond breaks
into a warehouse and there he finds
government agents filming a fake moon
landing sequence he steals a weird
looking moon buggy to escape
[Applause]
yeah that thing is almost as ugly as the
Tesla cyber truck a few years later the
movie Capricorn 1 starring James Brolin
and O.J Simpson was released oh did OJ
find a real killers yet ah not yet but
I'm sure they're hiding on a golf course
out there somewhere Capricorn one told
the story of a fake Mission to Mars as
Millions all over the world watched and
listened the president of the United
States spoke to the astronauts across
the vastness of space there's only one
small catch
it never happened it's all a lie so
because of these and other high-profile
references the idea of a fake moon
landing conspiracy really took off in
the 1970s now the 70s had the best
movies the best music you got a nice
Beaver nice Beaver you know how to do it
give me that nice Beaver nice Beaver you
know how to show it
what are you doing yeah that song's
gonna be stuck in my head all day now oh
you don't remember that one buddy BG's
nice Beaver Night Fever no Night Fever
that doesn't even make any sense well
what does he have the flu it's nice
Beaver it's not well if you spend as
much time at Club 54 as I did you know
that nice Beaver makes way more sense uh
that may be but the song is Night Fever
like really disagree the conspiracy
faded in the 80s but the internet helped
it make a comeback in the late 1990s by
the mid-2000s the idea that the moon
landings had been faked caught on with
Millennials who weren't alive for the
Apollo missions an extremely popular
documentary was the BART sabrel film a
Funny Thing Happened on the Way to the
Moon oh isn't that the guy that got
punched out by
butts the guy
you're the one who said you walked on
the moon when you didn't call in the
kettle black if you ever thought of
saying I misrepresented my wife from me
you're a coward and a liar and a thief
oh that old time it could really throw
hands huh he sure could but to be fair
sabriel had been chasing Buzz around
with the camera badgering him to swear
on the Bible that the moon landing was
real Buzz begged the guy to back off
which he didn't finally sabriel called
him a liar and a coward and he got a
knuckle sandwich for his trouble so the
moon landing conspiracy was back and
popping up all over American pop culture
they just start making stuff up yeah
like that Neil Armstrong guy have you
seen him on the talk shows any alarms
didn't mean the first man to walk in the
moon talk about a fish story
man and they're buying it okay
[Laughter]
and when Joe Rogan started questioning
the moon landing that exposed a theory
to a huge new audience
Joe Rogan comic podcaster between 1969
and 1972 they had seven attacks seven
seven attempts six of them successful
that was the only time in history that a
human being has been more than 400 miles
above the Earth's surface never heard of
him 400 000 people worked on the Apollo
project 600 million people watched the
moon landing live if this is a hoax it's
the greatest hoax in history bold claims
require bold evidence is there evidence
that the moon landing was faked
lots of it
has nobody been to believe in such a
long time
that's not
an eight-year-old's question
that's my question
the motivation for faking the moon
landings was driven by several factors
the United States was under tremendous
pressure to get to the moon before the
Soviets the Soviet Union had already
proven they were far ahead of the US in
space technology the exploration of
space will go ahead
whether we join in it or not
and it is one of the Great Adventures of
all time
and no Nation
which expects to be the leader of other
nations
can expect to stay behind the Soviet
Union put the first man-made object in
orbit with Sputnik 1 in 1957. they put
the first animal in space when Leica the
dog was launched with Sputnik 2. Leica
didn't survive but in 1960 the Soviets
launched two dogs and a bunch of mice
and rats that did return safely the
first human in space was Yuri Gagarin
Valentina tarshkova was the first woman
in space the first multi-person crew the
first spacewalk the first spacecraft to
reach the moon the first pictures of The
Far Side of the Moon and even the first
soft landing and transmission from the
moon's surface these were all Russian
achievements meanwhile America's
attempts to catch up were not going well
rumors started going around that the
Russians were going to put nuclear
weapons on the moon we have vowed that
we shall not see space
filled with weapons of mass destruction
but with instruments of knowledge so
there was tremendous public pressure to
get there first
[Applause]
[Music]
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade and do the other thing not
because they are easy but because they
are hard
on July 16 1969 Apollo 11 launched
successfully
four days later Neil Armstrong and Buzz
Aldrin set foot on the Moon
[Music]
it's one small step for man
in just a few years the United States
went from being years behind the Soviets
in space exploration to eclipsing all of
their achievements to many people this
was just too good to be true so Skeptics
started pouring over photographs and
film looking for evidence of a hoax and
the evidence was everywhere the first
clue of a hoax was that the astronauts
seemed to be casting shadows in two
different directions but the sun is the
only Light Source on the moon on Earth
Shadows run parallel on the Moon Not
only did Shadows Go in different
directions but sometimes they were at
right angles to each other the only way
to explain this is multiple light
sources like you'd get on a movie
soundstage studio lights would also
explain the shot
in a vacuum with only a single light
source the Shadows on the moon should be
absolutely completely black but there's
a lot of film and photos where even
though the astronauts are in Shadow
they're lit extremely well now in the
movies the sum would be called a key
light which is your main light and this
light in the shadows would be from
what's called a fill light but there's
no fill light on the moon only a key
light the sun there seems to be a
Hollywood lighting technique happening
here now you're not going to find any
direct evidence of studio lights in any
pictures from the Moon NASA is too smart
for that but even in big budget movies
you can sometimes see the cameras and
lights in reflections
now look at this in the reflection on
the helmet it looks like a neat row of
movie lights
and look at the reflection on this photo
what the heck is that that looks a lot
like a studio light with the barn doors
open
but here's a photo that shows what looks
like a movie prop this rock is labeled
with the letter c but the crew forgot to
remove the label when they started
shooting how about this picture of the
landing module do those Hills look like
they're miles away or do they look like
this was shot on a Sound Stage speaking
of those Hills this photo was supposedly
taken a few miles away from The Landing
module then how come the backgrounds are
identical because they use the same
backdrop now let's talk about stars on
Earth even with our thick atmosphere the
sky looks like this but on the moon with
no air the sky is just black shouldn't
the sky be full of stars NASA really
thought this went through if you're
gonna hoax Something In Space the stars
are a big problem this is because by
using a star map you can not only get
the precise location a photo was taken
you can even get the precise day and
time so they had to get rid of the Stars
when you looked up at the sky Could you
actually see the stars in the Solar
Corona in spite of the glare
we were never able to see stars from the
lunar surface or on the daylight Side of
the Moon by eye without looking through
the Optics
I don't recall during the period of time
that we were photographing the sonar
curl of what what stars we could see
[Music]
I don't remember seeing any
small problem they use stars to help
them navigate to the moon the astronaut
Navigator finds a known star in the wide
angle telescope
using a fingertip control he changes the
attitude of the spacecraft to bring the
star into line once he has the star in
position in the telescope he moves the
optical Sextant he lines The Sexton up
with the star and makes a reading
so are there stars or not which is it
there's a lot of evidence stacking up
that doesn't look good for NASA or the
moon landing and we're just warming up
foreign
the government fake the moon landing was
basically it was technically impossible
to do it and they simply had to come up
with some sort of alternative that they
felt the public would believe I believe
had they wanted to that NASA could
indeed have pulled off the greatest hoax
of all time never sent anyone to the
moon and recreated in a television
Studio can you realize that we that you
and I that all of us have actually begun
the exploration of another world
the United States Geological Survey
decided to fill the model of one part of
the lunar surface in an area accessible
to present research centers four
three
two
one fire
reflections of studio lights accidental
movie props repeating backdrops there's
a lot of evidence suggesting that the
moon landing wasn't filmed on the moon
but on a Sound Stage the lunar module
engine puts out 3 000 pounds of thrust
and the lunar surface is covered with
dust that was described as fine powder
if that's true why did the engine leave
no mark on the surface and shouldn't
there be dust everywhere even the foot
pads are clean and shiny so either the
landing module was sitting there or it
was gently lowered down by a crane and
you'd have to lower the thing gently
look at it it looks like tin foil and
curtain rods held together by duct tape
more evidence that a crane was used is
when the astronauts separate from the
module and return to orbit for pickup
look at this
the module separates and the astronauts
gently lift back to orbit and look how
slowly it moves where's the rocket plume
from the engine what's allowing this to
fly all the way to orbit if you watch
the footage closely it looks like the
object is wobbling a little on cables or
wires by the way who shot this footage
there was no camera remote control but
somehow the scene is framed perfectly
they're zooming in and out the camera
tracks the object up into the sky but
conveniently loses the object when it
gets too high but the camera does pan
around the surface who's working the
camera
now speaking of cables and wires look at
this footage
does this look natural
or does it look like he's being lifted
by wires
Apollo 11 this is Houston uh go ahead
[Music]
about all we can see from here
okay and uh reference to your question
on this uh Step 13 on the decal
uh I understand that you get used up uh
I've been
repress O2 package and at that time
instead of being
then there's this footage of Neil and
Buzz putting up the American flag but if
they were both on the moon's surface
who's shooting the footage and how is
the flag waving if there's no atmosphere
on the moon now sure we've been told
that there was an aluminum tube holding
up the flag but it seems to be moving
around a lot now here's a picture of
what an Apollo astronaut spacesuit
looked like but look at the soles of the
shoes they don't look anything like the
footprints the astronauts supposedly
made in the lunar dust and what about
the heat the surface temperature on the
Moon during the day is over 250 degrees
Fahrenheit that's as hot as an oven the
film inside their cameras should have
melted but there are thousands of
pictures that all came out perfectly
fine well fine except for the whole
wrong Shadows no stars movie props
visible lights and stuff being hoisted
by cranes right except for that and
there are plenty of photos that are flat
out doctored if you remember our episode
on NASA's Mars cover-up we proved that
the photos of Mars were altered before
being released to the public this is a
technique perfected during Apollo the
Apollo handheld cameras had special
crosshairs on them called her soul marks
and these were here to help make sure
the photos were printed properly from
the negatives and not distorted and to
make it easier to stitch photos together
for panoramas but in some of the photos
the crosshairs aren't there or are only
in part of the picture in other
photographs objects appear in front of
the crosshairs now that's physically
impossible unless the objects were added
after the photo was taken by layering
them on top of empty backgrounds and
there are even more problems with the
photography here's a picture of an
Apollo astronaut saluting the American
flag but look at his feet the Shadows
don't even reach them it's like he was
edited in later and somebody forgot to
add a shadow now even if we could
explain all these anomalies in the
photos
there's a big reason why nobody can get
to the moon a reason why human beings
can't leave Earth at all at least not
yet the reason is real and
scientifically proven as fact
radiation
we see the ascent stage suddenly pop up
without any exhaust plume whatsoever as
though it were jerked up by a cable I
research suggests that images of the
Apollo Landings are not a true and
accurate record in our view the Apollo
pictures were faint many of the images
are replete with inconsistencies and
anomalies
there are problems with almost every
aspect of the visual records equipment
and technology used to supposedly put a
man on the moon but there's one even
bigger problem we haven't dealt with yet
there's no way the astronauts could have
even escaped Earth's orbit much less
gone to the moon and back radiation in
1958 scientist James Van Allen
discovered two enormous belts of high
energy radiation surrounding the planet
the Van Allen radiation belts are a pair
of toroidal belts donut-shaped
pair of donut-shaped belts of high
energy particles any object leaving the
Earth's orbit to visit the moon or
Beyond has to pass through them and they
extend out about 37 000 miles from Earth
these two radiation belts have different
compositions the Inner Belt above the
equator contains energetic particles
that are charged up to a hundred million
electron volts the outer belt is
electron plasma from the sun's solar
wind and has energies in the 10 million
electron volt range when it was first
detected the strength of the radiation
was so powerful that scientists thought
they had recorded a Soviet nuclear test
these high energy particles can
penetrate spacecraft damaged instruments
and are lethal to astronauts but we have
photos and even film of the earth taken
from much farther out how could this be
faked well the astronauts never left low
earth orbit from there the Earth fills
the entire window of The Craft we only
have one window that has a view of the
earth and it's build up with the TV
camera so uh
so to get this film of the earth they
blocked out sections of the window this
film is an outtake the astronauts didn't
realize they were still rolling they
said the camera was pressed up against
the window to get a good shot of the
Earth but that's not true you can see
someone pass in front of the window then
quickly jump out of the way and here you
see the dim work light that was used so
they could operate the camera we're not
supposed to see this we're also not
supposed to see this someone adjusting
the insert that controls the shape of
the Earth
now remember they're in low earth orbits
so the Earth is actually really bright
and fills the whole window how do we
know because when they open up the iris
of the lens we can see it
holy
yeah we can't pass through the Van Allen
belts yet don't take my word for it take
nasus as we get further away from Earth
we'll pass through the Van Allen Bells
an area of dangerous
radiation
radiation like this could harm the
guidance systems onboard computers or
other electronics on Orion but Orion has
protection
shielding will be put to the test as the
vehicle cuts through the waves of
radiation
sensors aboard will record radiation
levels for scientists to study we must
solve these challenges before we send
people through this region of space I
guess we're still working on solving
this issue because I thought we we're
also really pushing the boundaries in
terms of where we're going forward with
exploration I think humans are naturally
driven to do this and this is really the
beginning I think of human beings
leaving low earth orbit I certainly plan
on being around to see that I don't want
to be a jerk because she seems like a
nice girl but newsflash the Moon is way
outside low earth orbit uh the plan that
NASA has is to build a rocket called SLS
which is a heavy lift rocket it's not is
that is much bigger than what we have
today
able to launch the Orion capsule with
human
as well as Landers or other components
to be to destinations beyond Earth orbit
right now we only can fly in Earth orbit
that's the farthest that we can go and
we only can fly in Earth orbit that's
the farthest that we can go and this new
system that we're building is going to
allow us to go beyond and hopefully take
humans into the solar system to explore
so the Moon Mars asteroids there's a lot
of destinations that we could go to
building block component
[Music]
once we travel Beyond low earth orbit
the crew will be exposed to larger
amounts of radiation so we have to
design both the crew Protection Systems
and our electronic systems to withstand
this radiation but didn't we already
design those protection systems for
Apollo why don't we just use that
technology I'd go to the moon in a
nanosecond the problem is we don't have
the technology to do that anymore we
used to but we destroyed that technology
and it's a painful process to build it
back again wait we destroyed the
technology and we can't recreate it so
nobody wrote anything down that seems
irresponsible well you mean
irresponsible like recording over the
original moon landing tapes yeah NASA
did that there are no original high
quality moon landing tapes they were
erased and reused allegedly
was taken in a very strange way NASA
took a video feed from the Moon and
projected it onto a screen the TV
stations pointed their cameras at the
screen the stations wanted a direct feed
but NASA refused that's why the moon
landing footage is such a mess anyway
the best way to protect a fragile human
body from Ben Allen radiation is lead
shielding but even a thin layer of lead
would have made the Saturn V rocket too
heavy to get off the ground the only
protection they had was a thin sheet of
aluminum but aluminum melts at about
1200 degrees Fahrenheit the electrons in
the van Allen belts have energies of
millions of volts now this would equate
to a temperature of about 10 million
degrees Kelvin so how did NASA overcome
this problem
they didn't instead they called
Hollywood
[Music]
I believe that this nation should commit
itself to achieving the goal
before this decade is out of Landing a
man on the moon and returning him safely
to the Earth
no single Space Project in this period
will be more impressive to mankind or
more important for the long-range
exploration of space but right now we
need a 10 to 12 year program that has as
its ultimate goal the man domination of
space and if we don't we're going to be
in trouble uh to put people on the moon
and with enough fuel to enable them to
return safely home to us requires is
still larger and more powerful rocket
however a member of Congress said today
that he was tired of being saying the
United States second
to Russia in a space field and only the
future will tell whether we'll manage to
close that Gap it's going to take some
time and I think we have to recognize
they secured these large boosters which
have led to their being first and
Sputnik and led to their first uh
putting their man in space we are I hope
going to be able to uh
carry out our efforts with due regard to
the problem of the life of the man
involved this year but we are behind we
are behind y'all behind
Kubrick's Odyssey is a short film
created by Jay Widener in 2011. recently
it gained attention after being picked
up by the Gaia streaming Network this
film is the primary reference for the
theory that Stanley Kubrick filmed the
moon landing footage for NASA in the
1960s and 70s by 1964 NASA knew that
sending men to the moon was impossible
the deadly radiation belts issues with
chemical rockets and weight and
radiation shielding issues it made it
unachievable Kubrick became involved
when someone in the Pentagon saw his
1963 film Dr Strangelove impressed by
the special effects this person offered
Kubrick a secret project faking the
Apollo moon landings Kubrick was
persuaded using a carrot and stick
approach if he helped fake The Landings
he would have artistic freedom and
financial support for his future films
that's the carrot the stick was
blackmail no one knows how the powers
that be convinced Kubrick to direct the
Apollo Landings maybe they had
compromised Kubrick in some way the fact
that his brother Raul Kubrick was the
head of the American Communist Party may
have been one of the Avenues pursued by
the government to get Stanley to
cooperate
so a deal was made in 1964. Kubrick was
given three years to complete 2001. in
order to test the filmmaking technology
necessary to make the moon landings
appear believable to a system he had
access to several NASA experts and the
use of a special 50 millimeter lens made
specifically for the Apollo program
originally was a lens manufactured
design developed and manufactured by
Zeiss for NASA so how did he do it
without the use of CGI Kubrick perfected
a new kind of visual effect called front
screen projection experimentation with
front screen projection began in 1949
shortly after the invention of
scotchlight a material used for screens
in movie theaters Scotch light is cloth
embedded with millions of tiny glass
beads that have high reflectivity due to
the sensitivity of scotch light a
minimal amount of light is required this
means that actors can stand in front of
the projection without it being visible
on their bodies or clothing front screen
projection was so convincing that many
people think the dawn of man sequences
in 2001 were actually shot on location
they weren't almost all that part of
2001 was shot in a studio with actors on
sets if you look closely at Apollo
photographs of the Moon you can see a
line where the fake moon set ends and
the front projection screen begins at
that line the texture of the lunar
surface changes dramatically please note
how everything is in focus from the
rocks and Pebbles close to the camera
all the way to the Crystal Clear
Mountain behind the astronaut there is a
stark difference in ground texture
between the set and what is being
projected onto the screen you can almost
count the number of small rocks and the
granularity of the ground that is
clearly seen on the set
once we get to the screen on the other
side of my line This granularity
disappears The Little Pebbles and dust
just seem to disappear behind my line
the latter part of Kubrick's Odyssey
discusses the hidden messages in The
Shining that Kubrick directed in 1980.
Kubrick leaves clues that he faked the
moon landings the characters Jack and
Danny who are the father and son in the
movie symbolize different aspects of
Kubrick's own personality Danny the
child represents Kubrick's inner
innocence while Jack represents the
jaded and morally compromised adult that
Kubrick has become there are also
specific visual Clues the Indian wall
hangings on the walls of the Overlook
Hotel look like rockets launching into
space the pattern on the carpet of the
hotel is a hexagonal shape that
represents the shape of the launch pads
at Cape Canaveral and in one scene when
Dany is playing with his toys on this
carpet he stands up and is seen wearing
a sweater that says Apollo 11 on it next
there's a scene where Dany then walks
down the hall and finds an open door to
a room the room is number 237 which was
changed from Room 217 in the same King
novel the number 237 is significant
because the average orbital distance
between the Earth and the moon is 237
000 miles then there's the scene where
Jack's wife discovers that he's been
typing the same phrase over and over the
phrases all work and no play makes Jack
a Dull Boy but the word all isn't a-l-l
it's actually typed out as a11 or Apollo
11. and there are a lot of other claims
made by Kubrick's Odyssey but those are
the highlights and these claims were
highly debated and very controversial
what we need is Kubrick admitting he
faked the moon landing we need to hear
it from his own mouth but he never said
a word about it
or Kitty
[Music]
we've been brought in here by Stanley
Kubrick to more or less ensure the
scientific Integrity of the film to make
sure that it's uh very very close in
reality but still we want to make sure
that it has a base of reality we're in
the final Assembly Building of the land
Santa cubic and I have set ourselves
several objectives we hope to convey to
the public the Wonder and beauty and
promise of the Age of Exploration which
which is opening up before the human
race
[Music]
good evening
I'm sorry not to be able to be with you
tonight
in 2016 an interview with Stanley
Kubrick was found and according to the
video Kubrick had to sign an 88-page
non-disclosure agreement that the
interview would stay hidden for 15 years
[Music]
is everything look in order regarding
our contract and the 15-year agreement
and
assigned the non-disclosure is that
that's all for the legal stuff right
yeah
okay looks good to me all right
a documentary filmmaker interviews
Stanley Kubrick about his career as a
director and right from the start
Kubrick interrupts and explains that
when he initially considered the project
he saw it as just another film when
asked which of his movies he's referring
to he reveals that he's talking about
the moon landing and claims that it was
all fake
challenge of making this
this film and and I went into it like it
was a regular film like a a another
production of mine
um not thinking too much about
uh the long-term
effects the the what it would mean
uh to to society if ever if it was ever
discovered
um but what are you talking about how do
you know what you're talking about
you're referring to something the fake
moon landing
he says that he was approached by NASA
and that they appealed to his sense of
Duty and patriotism but Cooper admitted
that the project was about America's
Public Image and upstaging Russia
to fulfill this dream that America has
had as a country since the Kennedy years
okay so you're saying the motivation was
PR PR absolutely plain simple PR
then he goes on to confirm that the
conspiracy is actually the truth fake
faking the exploration of space because
there was just no way we could get there
NASA then set up a meeting with Kubrick
and president Richard Nixon Kubrick met
with Nixon in the Oval Office and
details what Nixon asked him to do film
a fake moon landing
I am convinced and the gentleman at Nasa
are also convinced that you can help us
make people believe that we have been to
the Moon
this interview was a bombshell this was
the evidence the world had been waiting
for this was evidence that every
allegation made in the documentary
Kubrick's Odyssey was true yep millions
of people saw this interview and finally
felt justified in their suspicion that
the moon landing never happened yep one
small problem no no that wasn't Stanley
Kubrick
the Stanley Kubrick moon landing
confession set the conspiracy side of
the internet on fire but it was a hoax
this is either a filmmaker and an actor
or more likely two guys goofing around
in the full-length version of the
interview an agitated producer
constantly Badgers the actor whose real
name is Tom a launch pad accident n67
which kill Tom you're going to tell me a
story so next to sat me down the Oval
Office and he says to me you know that
boy just I don't think this is how I
want you when we're never going to need
help we're going to the deal yeah well
the plan
he didn't yeah so he says to me that if
you don't say he said anything you say
what he says okay
Tom I'm just giving you a question you
want me everything about it yo I walked
in and he said that's him you don't have
to imitate him but you have to say he
says Stanley we're working on this move
forward come on get with it Tom do your
do a get in the fact that
you're writing this time and now he's
got to be grab it can be funny in in a
very subtle way so you meet with Nixon
and what happened
in action
what they what they believed was if we
mix in sat down
caller tell me a story time
so Stanley Kubrick had nothing to do
with that interview not just that he had
nothing to do with the moon landing in
the documentary Kubrick's Odyssey
everything can be explained all the
photo evidence presented is from
extremely low resolution photos probably
grabbed from the web now unfortunately
for the documentary but lucky for us
high resolution photos can be found
easily so when looking at a low
resolution photo of the lunar landscape
you can maybe see a separation between
the foreground and the supposed backdrop
but in the high-res photos the line
isn't there
all the other claims in the documentary
that refer to photos can be explained
simply by looking at the originals as
far as the clues left in The Shining
those are nothing but coincidences and
stretches of the imagination the rockets
in the tapestry I don't really see it
the hexagonal rug well the launch pad at
Cape Canaveral is not a hexagon it was
roughly 10 sides but it's not very
symmetrical room 237 is just room 237.
the moon isn't 237 000 miles away from
the earth it's closer to 239 000 but
very slightly Danny is indeed wearing an
Apollo 11 sweater but Stanley Kubrick
was a space nut he loved the Apollo
program and he loved sci-fi and Stanley
Kubrick's brother Paul who is the leader
of the Communist Party well that's not
true at all Kubrick didn't have a
brother so that documentary is debunked
well maybe debunked maybe not no it's
debunked
it is
agree yeah but there's still a lot of
stuff in those pictures that looks
really fishy well that's true
the big one is that the Shadows should
be parallel since the Shadows are not
parallel there must be other light
sources except Shadows aren't parallel
the direction of Shadows depends on the
perspective of the viewer now here's an
example on Earth these are two pictures
of the same woman taken at different
angles in the first photo taken from the
side the Shadows are parallel but when
we put our back to the Sun the Shadows
aren't even close to parallel in
perspective drawing and design parallel
lines converge in what's called a
vanishing point this is typically the
horizon line where objects vanish beyond
our field of view plus the astronauts
used very wide lenses to capture as much
terrain as possible so images are going
to be slightly distorted like a carnival
mirror but even with a flatter lens or
the human eye shadows are not parallel
also multiple light sources would cast
multiple Shadows but the objects on the
moon cast only one Shadow yeah but every
there is no
there is
is the moon itself the soil on the
surface of the Moon is full of tiny
beads of Glass and Metal like aluminum
and titanium these are all highly
reflective materials so the moon soil
actually acts like trillions of tiny
mirrors bouncing the light back and
filling in the shadows we'll ever go
skiing on a sunny day of course I have I
was an instructor in college you were I
don't want to get into that now anyway
you can get a pretty bad sunburn skiing
not from the Sun overhead but by the sun
reflecting off the snow you could
actually burn your cornea with reflected
ultraviolet sunlight it's called snow
blindness so shadows and multiple light
sources bats all debunked now the same
background Theory might be my favorite
because it really defies explanation
until we look more closely oh the
backgrounds do not line up perfectly
they're slightly off because the photos
were taken pretty far apart the hills in
the distance look the same because
they're the same those Hills are miles
away but since there's no atmosphere on
the moon well since there's no water
vapor on the moon okay there's an
atmosphere on the moon but it's
extremely thin compared to the earth
it's called an exosphere and it's made
up of very small amounts of hydrogen
helium and a few Trace gases and because
there's no atmosphere there's no Haze we
evolved on Earth with a thick atmosphere
and one of the ways we determine distant
objects is by how hazy they are in other
words how much of the atmosphere are we
looking through now on the moon without
Haze objects both near and far will feel
close it's an optical illusion yeah but
where the Stars right the stars are
there you just can't see them they're
likely story in order to take pictures
of the Moon the camera's Iris had to be
almost completely closed and shutter
speed turned way up this is to let in as
little light as possible otherwise the
brightness of the Moon would wash
everything out look how bright a full
moon is on a clear night a full moon
lights up everything and it's a quarter
Million Miles Away the astronauts are
standing on that it's bright even on
Earth if you're standing under a big
Spotlight at night you're not going to
see stars the iris of your eye acts like
the iris of a camera the faint light of
the Stars just doesn't register watch a
baseball game played Under The Lights
You Don't See Stars
a lot of moon hoax evidence is
cherry-picked like the lack of a blast
crater under the lunar module there's no
crater because the engine was turned off
about 10 feet from the surface the limb
just dropped the rest of the way and
without any wind to disturb there's just
not going to be a lot of dust flying
around and where Apollo 11 touchdown the
ground was hard soil but other Apollo
Landings like Apollo 12 were pretty
dusty the lack of wind is also why the
American flag doesn't move well well the
aluminum rods are pretty springy so the
flag moves for quite a while after it's
touched but when it settles down it
doesn't move an inch oh the camera that
recorded the lunar module separating
that was operated remotely the
Footprints don't match because the
astronauts put on boot covers that have
a different tread
on the moon but without an atmosphere to
conduct heat there is no convection as
long as things are colored bright white
they reflect most of the sun's energy
pretty well heat wasn't an issue not for
the astronauts and not for the camera
film
now there are many more examples but I
think you get the idea every single one
of those pieces of evidence can be
explained
but hold on a second go on two questions
did NASA put men on the moon
probably is NASA covering something up
on the moon
definitely
my name is Carl wolf and I was a
Precision Electronics photographic
repairman with a top secret crypto
clearance
in mid-1965 I was loaned to the lunar
orbiter project at Nasa on Langley field
I was taken into the laboratory where
the equipment was malfunctioning I
couldn't repair it in the dark I asked
to have it removed a
Airman second class was in the dark room
at that time I was also an Airman second
class
about 30 minutes into the process he
said to me
um in a very distressed way
by the way we've discovered a base on
the back side of the moon and then he
proceeded to put photographs down in
front of me and clearly in these
photographs were structures
mushroom-shaped buildings spherical
buildings and Towers
and at that point I was very concerned
because I knew we were working on
compartmentalized security he had
breached security and I was actually
frightened at that moment and I did not
question him any further and a few
moments later someone did come into the
room
um I worked there for three more days
and I remember going home and naively
thinking I can't wait to hear about this
on the evening news
and here it is more than 30 years later
and I hope we hear about it tonight and
I will testify under oath before
Congress that what I'm saying is the
truth
[Applause]
I think the reason we haven't returned
to the moon for 50 years is not because
of a lack of Interest or funding or the
Van Allen radiation belts I think we
haven't gone back to the Moon because of
what was found up there but that
requires its own episode and if you want
to see it let me know whatever is up
there has been up there for a long long
time
and I think we can prove it
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that tacklefish
this has been the Y files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor
subscribe like comment share the buttons
all that stuff it really does help the
channel and like most topics we cover
here today's was recommended by you so
if there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the
whitefiles.com tips and if you'd like to
join a great Community full of thousands
of like-minded people who are weird like
us check out the y-files Discord it's
free to join and a lot of fun and
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible we could not do
this without your support and if you'd
like to support the channel and keep the
Y files going become a member on patreon
for as little as three dollars a month
you get all kinds of fun perks and you
get to see the videos early without
commercials or buy something from the
Wi-Fi store get yourself a Heckle fish
t-shirt
animals
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]